أنت تقول إن لديك احتياطيات كافية
لضمان قدرة هذا البلد على تجنب
الانهيار الاقتصادي طالما
تم تسوية الوضع السياسي هنا ، هل
نتحدث أيام أسابيع شهور إنها
مسألة أيام لأن التكلفة باهظة
على البلد ولكن الأهم
نفقد الثقة اليومية المزيد
والمزيد من الثقة والتمويل
والاقتصاد ، الأمر كله يتعلق بالثقة في أن
البنوك
مغلقة ، فالأصل الحقيقي للبنان هم
اللبنانيون الذين يعملون خارج جاسبيرا إذا
لم يروا حلاً يعطي
آمالاً بالأمل  المستقبل
فإن هذه التدفقات التي يعتمد عليها لبنان
ستتقلص بشكل مهم
ومن أجل إنقاذ هذا
الوضع نحتاج إلى حل فوري.
الكرة يتأخر الحل
كلما كلف البلد اليوم
لا يوجد نشاط اقتصادي في
البلد.  أصبح من الصعب
توجيه الواردات لأن البنوك مغلقة وأصبح
فتح خطابات الاعتماد أكثر
صعوبة مما كان عليه قبل أن يكون لدينا
دوليًا  الديون أيضًا لتغطيتها ، وإذا
لم نغطها ، فنحن في وضع افتراضي
، ومن ناحية أخرى ، فإن
وظائف الأشخاص معرضة للخطر لأن
الشركات التي تخسر المال قد
تتعرض لخطر عدم القدرة على دفع
الرواتب.  اليوم
قضية دولة متوقفة في
نشاطها ولا تستطيع تحمل ذلك